das empire state building mitten im
herzen new yorks
mutter aller wolkenkratzer
und symbol des amerikanischen traums
ein echter klassiker
das empire state building die welt der
architektur verändert doch was geschieht
wenn
dieser klassiker
auf eine ikone der neuzeit trifft
niemand weiß wie so ein vergleich
ausgeht das empire state building gegen
den burj khalifa der höchste
wolkenkratzer der welt die ikone dubais
ein gigantisches gebäude das
buchstäblich in den himmel wächst bis
heute hat es niemand geschafft nach
höher zu bauen ein wettstreit der
superlative zwei kontrahenten drei
kategorien und jede menge überraschungen
architektur
welcher wolkenkratzer revolutionierte
die baukunst
ausstattung welches gebäude bietet mehr
technische innovation
[Musik]
und stabilität welcher wolkenkratzer
steht für die ewigkeit
das duell jetzt bei ikonen
[Musik]
manhattan new york berühmt für seine
wolkenkratzer
eine skyline voller glitzer giganten
[Musik]
mittendrin das empire state building der
wohl legendärste wolkenkratzer der welt
er richtet im jahr 1930 mit einem klaren
ziel
der bauherr fragte die architekten wie
hoch können sie bauen ohne dass es
umfeld ein gebäude wie es die welt noch
nie gesehen hat mit unglaublichen
443 metern höhe bis zur spitze
erschaffen aus mehr als 730 tonnen stahl
und aluminium und zehn millionen
ziegelsteinen
[Musik]
260.000 quadratmeter mietfläche auf 100
2 etagen
ein ganz besonderer arbeitsplatz für
über 20.000 menschen
[Musik]
es ist ein meilenstein der baugeschichte
und bis heute einer der größten
touristenattraktionen der vereinigten
staaten
doch kann es auch im 21 jahrhundert mit
den ikonen der gegenwart mithalten
dubai am persischen golf
nirgends auf der welt gibt es mehr
wolkenkratzer mit einer höhe von über
300 metern
seine skyline stellt sämtliche städte
weltweit ob in europa amerika oder asien
in den schatten
wenn man von der wüste aus auf dubai
blick wirken die funkelnden hochhäuser
wie eine fata morgana und mittendrin der
burj khalifa das höchste bauwerk der
erde mit 828 metern bricht das gebäude
alle rekorde
und das mit deutlichem vorsprung
[Musik]
erschaffen aus über
330.000 kubikmetern beton und 100 3000
quadratmetern glas
mit mehr als 300 9000 quadratmetern
mietfläche und über 160 stockwerken
gleicht der burj khalifa einer
vertikalen statt
[Musik]
der burj khalifa und das empire state
building sind zwei beeindruckende
bauwerke beide sind meisterleistungen
der ingenieurs kunst jederzeit
state building gegen burj khalifa der
wettstreit beginnt
die erste hauptkategorie architektur
welcher wolkenkratzer hat es geschafft
die baukunst zu revolutionieren
new york anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
die wirtschaft boomt und einwanderer aus
aller welt strömen in die stadt der
träume uns in manhattan gibt es nur noch
eine richtung nach oben
doch mit der massivbauweise lohnte es
sich nicht häuser mit wirklich großer
höhe zu bauen denn je höher ein gebäude
war desto dicker mussten die außenwände
sein das verringerte die nutzbare fläche
jahrtausendelang wurden häuser auf
dieselbe weise gebaut ihre traglast
route ausschließlich auf den wänden und
decken mit jedem zusätzlichen stockwerk
musste das ziegelwerk der außenwände
verstärkt werden
dann kam eine innovation die new york
und manhattan für immer veränderte der
stahlskelett baum
es ist eine revolution in der
architektur das stahlgerüst im inneren
der bauwerke trägt dabei das gesamte
gewicht die hülle um sie herum ist nur
noch fassade
[Applaus]
als pionier dieser technik gilt das home
insurance building in chicago mit 42
metern höhe gilt es als erstes modernes
hochhaus der welt
diese neue technik machen sich die
schöpfer des empire state buildings zu
nutze und erreichen mit hilfe des
stahlskelett baus ungeahnte höhen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ende der 20er jahre tobt in new york ein
erbitterter wettkampf um den höhenrekord
die investoren versprechen sich davon
jede menge prestige und entsprechend
auch höhere mieteinnahmen
[Musik]
mit dem empire state building wollten
sie den höhen wettlauf unbedingt
gewinnen
die bauherren reizen die neue bauweise
bis aufs letzte aus
[Musik]
der kern des empire state buildings ist
320 meter hoch bestehend aus senkrechten
und waagerechten stahlträger darüber
folgt ein rund 60 meter hoher turm aus
weiteren stahlträgern den abschluss
bildet damals eine 67 meter hohe antenne
das ziel dient die stahlträger verleihen
ihm eine enorme tragfähigkeit außerdem
wird dank dieser technik weniger
grundfläche benötigt ein großer vorteil
im teuren manhattan
und so erreicht das gebäude am ersten
mai 1931 eine strukturelle höhe von
381 metern
als krönung erhält das empire state
building später einen eigenen sitz
auch das empire state building tipp für
lange zeit der höchste wolkenkratzer der
stadt skelett bau und die möglichkeiten
der damaligen technik waren ausgeschöpft
40 jahre lang bleibt der wolkenkratzer
das höchste gebäude der welt
[Musik]
erst 1972 stellt das world trade center
mit 417 metern höhe einen neuen rekord
auf
[Musik]
es ist der beginn einer neuen ära zwei
jahre später wagt der sears tower in
chicago
442 meter in die höhe
1998 folgen die petronas towers in kuala
lumpur mit 452 metern
und in taiwan knackte stypmann im jahr
2003 erstmals die 500 meter marke
[Musik]
doch auch dieser rekord wird nicht lange
seit 2010 über ragt der burj khalifa
nicht nur die skyline dubais sondern
auch alle anderen wolkenkratzer weltweit
und das um mehr als unglaubliche 300
meter wie ist es möglich so ein ausnahme
bauwerk zu erschaffen
nach der fertigstellung des burj khalifa
ging eine welle der ehrfurcht durch die
ingenieurs branche
mit ihm begann das zeitalter der mega
tower buildings
das geheimnis verbirgt sich auch hier im
kern der konstruktion
die architekten setzen auf einen psion
förmigen grundriss mit drei
gebäudeflügeln
die flügel stützen sich gegenseitig ab
und laufen in der zentralen achse
zusammen
diese konstruktion ist einzigartig sie
ist stabil ermöglicht viel lichteinfall
und macht den wolkenkratzer extrem
aerodynamische
in seinem inneren befindet sich ein
sechseckiger kern aus hochfestem beton
der bis unter die stahlkonstruktion der
spitze reicht die flügel unter kern
zusammen garantieren eine bis dahin noch
nie erreichte stabilität gegen vertikale
und horizontale kräfte
ursprünglich planen die bauherren
lediglich eine höhe von 510 meter
doch die y konstruktion erweist sich in
statik tests als noch leistungsfähiger
[Musik]
die auftraggeber hörten dass sie ihren
wolkenkratzer sogar noch höher bauen
könnten wollten sie mehr so hoch wie
möglich koste es was es wolle sogar noch
während des baus treiben die bauherren
die höhe immer weiter nach oben
endgültiger stand
828 meter
der burj khalifa ist damit das höchste
bauwerk der menschheitsgeschichte nur
möglich dank des statischen rückgrats
seiner einzigartigen y konstruktion
beide gebäude haben mit ihrer bautechnik
rekorde aufgestellt und werden zu recht
dafür gerühmt
zeit für die zweite runde in der
kategorie architektur
welcher wolkenkratzer punktet in sachen
geschwindigkeit und effizienz
der bau des empire state buildings
beginnt am 17 märz 1930 unter
schwierigen bedingungen
die baustelle liegt zwischen zwei
hauptverkehrsstraßen zu
denen gibt es nirgendwo in manhattan
genug platz um die gigantischen bau
segmente zwischenzulagern
lichtlösung hat die damalige logistik
branche revolutioniert sie erinnert an
die heutige just in time beschaffung
bekommt
zwei stahlwerke im 500 kilometer
entfernten pittsburgh gießen die träger
teile exakt nach den anweisungen der
architekten der zug und lastwagen
erreichen sie die ostküste und sind nach
nur acht stunden an der baustelle in
manhattan
die ausgeklügelte logistik trägt dazu
bei dass das empire state building in
rekordzeit fertig wird die stahlträger
waren angeblich oft noch warm wenn sie
von den kränen empor gehievt wurden der
nächste klub erstmals stehen die
baukräne nicht neben dem gebäude sondern
auf dem wachsenden rohbau
nach fertigstellung einer etage bauen
die arbeiter die kräne ab und ein
stockwerk höher wieder auf so schaffen
sie rund viereinhalb etagen pro woche
indeed wenn die troika fand henry ford
die erste produktionslinie für autos
beim empire state buildung betrug man
dieses system von der horizontalen in
die vertikale
die reine bauzeit gerade einmal 13
monate und das empire state building ist
mit kosten von 41 millionen us-dollar
sogar günstiger als gedacht schnell und
gleichzeitig effizient
ob die erbauer des burj khalifa da noch
eins draufsetzen
heutzutage sind selbst klettern der
kräne autohaus baustellen zwar weltweit
standard doch in dubai kämpfen die
ingenieure mit einem ganz anderen
problem
[Musik]
hitze in der wüstenstadt herrschen
tagsüber temperaturen von bis zu 50 grad
celsius
normaler beton härtet bei diesen
temperaturen zu schnell aus
deshalb betonieren die arbeite
hauptsächlich bei nacht und geben
zusätzlich wasser und eis in die
mischung bis der burj khalifa die
bauhöhe des empire state buildings
erreicht braucht es fast 80 jahre später
die doppelte zeit
khalifa ist fast doppelt so hoch der
transport nach oben dauert länger drei
eigens entwickelte hochleistungspumpen
befördern bis zu 33 kubikmeter beton pro
stunde auf mehr als 600 meter höhe
und dann ist da noch die fassade anders
als bei der new yorker ikone besteht sie
nicht aus kalkstein und granit sondern
aus glas und aluminium
die fassadenteile verzögerten den
gesamten zeitplan ein lieferant den
pleite das kostete monate am ende musste
die eröffnung um ein jahr verschoben
werden in sechs baujahren verschlingt
die konstruktion circa 1,5 milliarden us
dollar
berücksichtigt man die inflation ist das
fast dreimal so viel wie beim empire
state building
in sachen geschwindigkeit und effizienz
lässt der bursch gegenüber dem empire
state building also ordentlich federn
wer so hoch hinaus will muss mit
rückschlägen rechnen
zeit für runde drei in sachen
architektur
welche arbeiter haben es überhaupt
ermöglicht diese gigantischen bauten zu
erschaffen
das empire state building wäre ohne die
arbeit der mohawk nicht möglich gewesen
die hochseilartisten ohne jede sicherung
balancieren die angehörigen dieser
indigenen nationen über den schluchten
new yorks in 300 metern höhe
seit 1916 machten sich mohawk männer auf
die reise nach new york um auf hochhaus
baustellen zu arbeiten
fast alle bekannten wolkenkratzer new
yorks werden bis heute mit ihrer
unterstützung errichtet
sicherheitsvorkehrungen gibt es damals
fast keine
[Musik]
nach offiziellen angaben kommt es zu
fünf tödlichen unfällen wobei die new
york daily news von 14 toten berichtet
insgesamt riskieren bis zu
3500 menschen ihr leben um das
einzigartige empire state building zu
erschaffen jobs zentralen kurz vor
baubeginn erlebt die wall street den
schlimmsten börsencrash des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
der verheerende kurseinbruch stürzt die
gesamte welt in eine tiefe
wirtschaftskrise
ein boot mit einer solchen katastrophe
hatte damals niemand gerechnet in den
usa stieg die arbeitslosenquote von 3
auf fast 25 prozent
millionen menschen verlieren ihr
vermögen ihren arbeitsplatz und ihre
rente die wirtschaft liegt am boden
die erbauer des empire state buildings
drängen trotz krise darauf das projekt
durchzuziehen
wer geld verdienen muss riskiert sein
glück in luftiger höhe auch in den
reservaten der mohawk herrschen armut
und arbeitslosigkeit
aus wut und übung wird so eine tradition
die skywalker aus new york sorgen damals
wie heute dafür dass wolkenkratzer in
den himmel wachsen können
mut braucht es auch in dubai der stadt
der architektonischen superlative
heutzutage sind die sicherheitsmaßnahmen
auf hochhausbau stellen zwar deutlich
verbessert doch auch beim bau des burj
khalifa kommt es berichten zufolge zu
einem tödlichen unfall
bis heute braucht diese architektur
furchtlose kletterer die sich bis ganz
nach oben warten es ist ein drahtseilakt
die spitze des burj khalifa hat einen
durchmesser von nur einem meter und
diese soll hell erstrahlen möglich macht
das ein mann industriekletterer mit
flirty er soll sieben löcher in den 55
millimeter dickem stahl bohren
und die strahler einsetzen doch noch ist
der job nicht zu ende
flaherty muss sich abseilen und die
fugen abdichten
jetzt wird es ernst
sehr ernst
bist du bereit ja fertig
okay es geht los es ist ein weiter weg
nach unten ein sehr weiter weg
die ironie der geschichte
eigentlich sollte jemand anderes diesen
job übernehmen aber der ursprünglich
angeheuerte kletterer kneift in letzter
sekunde so wird flaherty diese ehre
zuteil
jetzt muss ich die fugen noch versiegeln
in über 800 metern höhe
geschafft clarity bringt das höchste
gebäude der welt zum leuchten
wer fertig
seht ihr darum geht's man muss seine
arbeit lieben
bis heute sind es keine maschinen die
diesen bauwerken ihren glanz verleihen
sondern helden der arbeit aus fleisch
und blut
zwischenfazit in sachen architektur
beeindruckend beide wolkenkratzer
während der burj khalifa mit seinem
höhenrekord herausragt kann das empire
state building mit seiner rasend
schnellen bauzeit punkten
das duell der wolkenkratzer geht in die
zweite runde ausstattung welches gebäude
bietet mehr innovation
rush hour in manhattan seit 100 jahren
strömen die büroarbeiter hier in immer
höhere gebäude
die entscheidende frage
damals wie heute bekommen sie möglichst
schnell nach oben die lösung klingt
einfach auf züge
[Musik]
was wir für selbstverständlich halten
war für die wolkenkratzer bahnbrechend
lange gelten aufzüge als tödliche gefahr
zwar werden sie schon ende des 17ten
jahrhunderts erfunden doch ständig
kursieren meldungen von schrecklichen
unfällen immer wieder reißen seile
niemand wollte damals mit dem aufzug
fahren es war den leuten einfach zu
gefährlich das änderte sich erst 100
jahre nach seiner erfindung nach den
ereignissen von 1854
auf der weltausstellung in new york
präsentiert der junge amerikaner
erlischt grace otis den erste absturz
sicheren aufzug
das besondere er besitzt eine
automatische bremse reist ein sub seil
dehnt sich eine feder aus verteilt sich
in der führungsschiene des fahrstuhls
und fängt die kabine ab die vorher
konnten die leute im fahrstuhl im
notfall nur eine art handbremse ziehen
über die jahre entwickelt otis seiner
aufzüge weiter im empire state building
fahren 64 stück davon täglich rauf und
runter
die vier express aufzüge fahren sogar
ohne zwischenstopp vom zweiten bis in
den 80ern stock
höchstgeschwindigkeit sechs meter pro
sekunde von dort aus gelangen die
passagiere über einen kleineren lift zur
aussichtsplattform in 320 metern höhe
54 sekunden dauert die fahrt in den
80ern stock für die besucher eine
unvergessliche erfahrung die aufzüge
zählen zu den schnellsten und
fortschrittlichsten ihrer zeit
erst 2011 werden sie durch digitale
modelle ersetzt
seit damals hat sich viel getan heute
gilt es mehr als je zuvor möglichst
viele menschen in kürzester zeit ganz
nach oben zu befördern vor allem im
höchsten gebäude der welt
wie schnell kommen die fahrgäste hier
bis zur spitze
der burj khalifa setzt auf sailauf züge
der neuesten generation genauer gesagt
57 aufzüge weniger als im empire state
building doch es gibt einen clou zwei
aufzüge sind doppelstock ich
einen doppelstock auf zu können in einem
schacht zwei kabinen übereinander
gleichzeitig waren das spart platz und
erhöht die effizienz
die doppelstock aufzüge gehören mit zehn
metern pro sekunde zu den schnellsten
der welt doch auch im burj khalifa
müssen die fahrgäste umsteigen wenn sie
ganz nach oben wollen
denn ab 500 metern kommt das material
der tragseile an seine grenzen jenseits
dieser marke wird das gewicht der
stahlseile zu groß und die seile würden
durch ihr eigengewicht reist
[Musik]
an diesem punkt stoßen die hersteller an
ihre grenzen 500 meter ist die maximale
höhe die ein aufzug erreichen kann
ein aufzug befördert die besucher
zunächst in die 124 etage in 456 metern
höhe ein weiterer bringt die passagiere
von dort in das
148 stockwerk zur weltweit höchsten
aussichtsplattform in 5 155 metern höhe
[Applaus]
von der lobby bis zu ersten
aussichtsplattform brauchen die
passagiere nur 55 sekunden um den blick
auf dubai zu genießen in einer höhe von
über
450 metern
zwischenfazit in sachen geschwindigkeit
und höhe sind die aufzüge im burj
khalifa denen des empire state buildings
zu überlegen jedoch sind beide systeme
für ihre zeit bahnbrechend
aber geschwindigkeit ist nicht alles wie
sieht es aus in sachen komfort wo lebt
und arbeitet es sich luxuriöser new
yorker sommer sind egal ob heute oder
vor 100 jahren heiß und stickig
manhattan besteht abseits des central
parks vor allem aus asphalt und beton
und fängt die hitze regelrecht ein
[Musik]
gerade für die büroangestellten in den
oberen etagen wurde der sommer zur qual
denn damals setzte man noch auf
natürliche belüftung luxus sieht heute
anders aus
deshalb setzen die architekten des
empire state buildings auf eine fassade
aus stahl und kalkstein sie sollen die
kühle nachtluft möglichst lange
speichern und dafür sorgen dass sich die
fassade tagsüber nicht aufheizt doch im
sommer reicht die natürliche isolation
der fassade nicht aus die menschen
versuchen sich mit ventilatoren zu
behelfen
dabei ist die erste klimaanlage der welt
bereits erfunden
gilles carrier tüftelt über jahre an
seiner erfindung
eine maschine die warme luft mittels
filter gereinigt und befeuchtet und ganz
nebenbei auch noch kühlt im sommer 1902
gera derne klima anlage in betrieb doch
bis zum erfolg ist es ein weiter weg
erfindung zielte nicht auf die kühlung
der luft ab sondern auf ihre reinigung
deswegen dauerte es eine ganze zeit bis
ich die vorteile der klimaanlagen herum
sprachen eine ironie der
technikgeschichte
als einer der ersten erkennen die
besitzer des new yorker rivoli kinos
dass eine klimaanlage vor allem eins
macht kühlen immer mehr kinos und
kaufhäuser folgen in wolkenkratzern
hingegen dauert es
[Musik]
das empire state building erhält erst
1950 48 jahre nach ihrer erfindung eine
zentrale klimaanlage
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rückblickend betrachtet war das empire
state building recht spät dran mit
dieser innovation doch zur bauzeit waren
klimaanlagen noch nicht populär und
später scheute man lange die kosten
dafür in
sachen komfort kann das gebäude ersten
jahre später punkten
aber immerhin wurde die klimaanlage
seitdem schon zweimal modernisiert
in dubai sind temperaturen von 50 grad
celsius keine seltenheit die
luftfeuchtigkeit erreicht im sommer bis
zu 90 prozent extreme lebensverhältnisse
die extreme lösungen erfordern
auch weil die fassade des burj khalifa
vorwiegend aus glas besteht die silberne
außenhülle soll dem wolkenkratzer
wortwörtlich glanz verleihen hier
komfortabel leben und arbeiten zu können
ist eine echte herausforderung für die
erbauer
die glasfassade lässt zwar viel licht
ins gebäude aber gleichzeitig heizen
sich die räume auf im extremen klima von
dubai könnte selbst die stärkste
klimaanlage nicht dagegen ankommen
deshalb entwickeln ingenieure ein
spezialglas für den burj khalifa mit
einer doppel beschichtung aus titan und
silber die die sonneneinstrahlung auf 18
prozent reduziert
in kombination mit dem spezialglas sorgt
eine zentrale lüftungs und klimaanlage
für ein konstantes raumklima und frische
luft im burj khalifa auch in den
aufzügen
so bleibt es egal ob im erdgeschoss oder
im 160 stockwerk immer angenehm kühl
[Musik]
ergebnis was komfort und mikroklima
angeht übertrumpft der burj khalifa das
mittlerweile 90-jährige empire state
building
doch welcher der beiden wolkenkratzer
ist eigentlich wirtschaftlich
erfolgreicher welche hat die größere
anziehungskraft
das empire state building wird als
riesiger bürokomplex entworfen auf
100 2 etagen sollen bis zu 20.000
menschen arbeiten auf über
260.000 quadratmeter
für besucher gibt es aussichtsterrassen
im 86 und 100 zweiten stockwerk
ich bin vor doch selbst fünf jahre nach
der eröffnung stand das gebäude oberhalb
der 41 etage fast völlig leer der
wolkenkratzer wurde deswegen als mt
state building bezeichnet
an der technik oder der ausstattung
liegt es nicht der grund ist ein völlig
anderer mittlerweile hat die
weltwirtschaftskrise zugeschlagen in
ganz manhattan stehen gebäude und büros
leer
nur der hartnäckigkeit des früheren
gouverneurs und präsidentin der empire
state corporation als miss ist es zu
verdanken dass das bauprojekt doch noch
erfolg hatte
sein ziel durch geschickte pr arbeit aus
dem bürogebäude eine sehenswürdigkeit
machen und damit zahlende interessenten
anlocken
mevlut berühmte persönlichkeiten ein er
begrüßte prinz feisal aus saudi arabien
und sogar winston churchill bei ihren
visiten
[Musik]
die nächste aktion die zeppelin an dog
station an der spitze des wolkenkratzers
ein einziges mal ankert ein luftschiff
dort oben für ganze drei minuten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der people damals hielt man den
zeppelin für das fortbewegungsmittel der
zukunft
es kam zwar anders aber die aktion
sorgte für viele schlagzeilen
auch hollywood rührt die werbetrommel in
der schlusssequenz von king kong
erklimmt der riesen affe die spitze des
empire state buildings
nach der premiere schnellen die
besucherzahlen in die höhe
in den folgejahren dient der
wolkenkratzer unzähligen filmen als
kulisse und tatsächlich wird der
steigenden berühmtheit kommen endlich
auch die mieter
doch es dauert fast zwei jahrzehnte bis
das gebäude schließlich profit abwirft
und
damit ist das empire state building
nicht allein denn es gibt einen
seltsamen zusammenhang zwischen
wolkenkratzern und wirtschaftskrisen
man spricht vom fluch der rekord
wolkenkratzer angeblich sind sie ein
indikator für einen nahenden
wirtschaftskrise
wann immer einen mega wolkenkratzer
errichtet wurde ließ die nächste
rezession nicht lange auf sich warten
nach der eröffnung des world trade
centers kommt es 1973 zu ersten ölkrise
[Musik]
der bau der petronas towers 1997 fällt
genau in die asienkrise
und kurz nach fertigstellung des tai pan
platz im jahr 2000 die dot-com-blase
experten vermuten ein ökonomisches
phänomen solche bauprojekte werden nur
in angriff genommen den bauherren und
banker die zukunft sehr optimistisch
sehen und bereit sind große risiken
einzugehen das ist oft kurz vor einer
rezession der fall
wie beim empire state building herrscht
auch im burj khalifa anfangs viel
leerstand zwar sind 90 prozent der
apartments bereits an investoren
verkauft die mieter dazu fehlt jedoch
ein paar jahre nach dem baustart des
burj khalifa begann die globale
finanzkrise von 2007 die zur eröffnung
im jahr 2010 für leerstand im gebäude
sorgte die betreiber versuchten alles um
den wolkenkratzer attraktiver zu machen
dabei bietet der burj khalifa luxus pur
zwischen der ersten und der 39 etage
befindet sich das erste armani hotel der
welt in den stockwerken darüber liegen
1044 private luxus residenzen und büros
auf dem 124 und dem 148 stockwerk
befinden sich zwei außenterrassen für
besucher für shopaholics bietet die
dubai mall am fuße des wolkenkratzers
1200 geschäfte mittlerweile verbindet
sogar ein unterirdischer durchgang moll
und rekord wolkenkratzer und
die größten wasserspiele der welt sollen
den burj khalifa noch attraktiver machen
auf einer länge von
275 metern schiessen wasserfontänen bis
zu 150 meter in die höhe nicht einmal
las vegas kann da mithalten
wie beim empire state building
überlegten sich auch die betreiber des
burj khalifa unzählige pr-aktionen die
taten alles um ihn permanent in den
schlagzeilen zu halten
eine der ideen der goldbarren automat
statt geldscheinen spuckt er pures gold
aus zumindest für zahlungskräftiges
publikum
auch hollywood prestige soll für den
wirtschaftlichen erfolg sorgen
für den film mission impossible phantom
protokoll hält schauspieler tom cruise
bei einem stand an der glitzernden
außenfassade des gebäudes
dann all diese attraktion ist der burj
khalifa heute der platzhirsch unter den
wolkenkratzern
trotzdem stehen einige apartments noch
leer
beide ikonen kämpfen nach ihrer
eröffnung viele jahre lang um den
wirtschaftlichen erfolg obwohl sie
längst kultstatus besitzen
[Musik]
fazit der zweiten kategorie in sachen
innovation kann es der klassiker nicht
ganz mit der ikone der neuzeit aufnehmen
aber vielleicht punktet er ja in der
dritten kategorie stabilität welcher der
beiden wolkenkratzer wird länger bestand
haben
eine der größten herausforderungen für
die lebensdauer von wolkenkratzern ist
der wind
wie stark die wind kräfte an der spitze
des empire state buildings sind zeigt
ein außergewöhnlicher vorfall im jahr
1979 im dezember 1979 stürzte sich rwe
dahms vom 86 stock in die tiefe der
allerdings wurde sie von einer starken
windböe erfasst und wieder zurück auf
die 85 c etage getragen sie überlebte
mit einer gebrochenen hüfte
am höchsten punkt des empire state
buildings kann der wind mit 130
kilometern pro stunde aufs gebäude
treffen
dank seiner robusten bauweise hält das
gebäude dieser winters zwar stand
allerdings tritt bei wolkenkratzern ein
weiteres aero dynamisches problem auf
das neben der geschwindigkeit mit der
der wind aufs gebäude prallt sind vor
allem die seiten wirbel gefährlich
die luft strömt um den wolkenkratzer
herum und bildet wirbel an den seiten
diese tiefdruckgebiete saugen das
gebäude seitlich an die weiter oben
desto stärker die wirbel deswegen für
jungen die bauherren die form des empire
state buildings nach oben die schmalere
außenhülle bietet dem wind eine kleinere
angriffsfläche und sorgt dafür dass das
gebäude kaum ins schwanken gerät
[Musik]
durch diese bauweise gibt die spitze des
wolkenkratzers selbst bei orkanartigem
wind nur etwa 4 cm nach
wie sieht's beim burj khalifa aus dubai
wird regelmäßig von wüstensand stürmen
heimgesucht
an seiner spitze kann der wind bis zu
240 kilometer pro stunde erreichen rund
doppelt so viel wie beim empire state
building
[Musik]
wie hält der über 800 meter hohe
wolkenkratzer dieser enormen windlast
statt
bei einem projekt in der größenordnung
des burj khalifa mussten die architekten
sich sehr früh gedanken darüber machen
wie sie dieses problem lösen
ein konstruktionsfehler könnte sehr
schnell fatale konsequenzen haben
die lösung der architekten sie
analysieren die frau herrschenden
luftströmungen und richten das gebäude
danach aus
bläst der wind gegen eine seite der
ypsilon konstruktion bleibt der
dahinterstehende flügel unbelastet und
stabilisiert den burj khalifa
zusätzlich schwächen und brechen 26
terrassen die wind verwirbelungen an den
seiten des wolkenkratzers
zur aero dynamischen verbesserung werden
die flügel abgerundet
die erbauer wählten eine runde form sie
bietet im wind weniger angriffsfläche
wie auch dann ein paar state building
verjüngt sich die form des burj khalifa
nach oben
durch diese geschickte kombination
architektonische elemente können die
gefährlichen seiten wirbel dem burj
khalifa kaum etwas anhaben
selbst bei orkanartigem wind schwankt
die spitze nur um einen meter 40 fazit
sowohl der burj khalifa als auch das
empire state building trotzten dank
ihrer form windlast und seiten wirbeln
völlig problemlos
doch wie gefährlich wird es bei einem
erdbeben halten die beiden wolkenkratzer
auch einer naturkatastrophe stand im
vergleich zu den westlichen us staaten
zählt die ostküste zu den seismisch eher
inaktiven regionen doch um new york gibt
es immer wieder kleinere erdbeben
statistisch gesehen ist alle 100 jahre
sogar ein beben der stärke 5 fällig
erdbeben in new york sind aber die
gegend wird intensiv genutzt und ist
sehr dicht besiedelt würden sich die
erdstöße direkt unter dem stadtzentrum
ereignen wäre das katastrophal
auch beim bau des empire state buildings
müssen die bauherren den möglichen
ernstfall berücksichtigen
damit der wolkenkratzer bei erdbeben
nicht in eine gefährliche seitenlage
kommt benötigt er zuerst ein verstärktes
fundament
das besteht aus
210 betonpfeilern die bis zu 17 meter
tief in den boden reichen
ein dutzend dieser säulen ragt 320 meter
in die höhe und bildet den rahmen des
stahlskelett
erste wolkenkratzer mit einem solchen
verstärkten fundament und das vorbild
für das ein paar estate bildung
durch dieses verfahren liegt der
schwerpunkt enorm tief doch das ist
nicht der einzige grund warum der
wolkenkratzer erdbeben trotzt häuser aus
stein sind star bei erschütterungen
nicht gerade ein vorteil
ganz anders beim empire state building
denn auch wenn es steil und unwegsam
wirkt sein stahlgerüst ist äußerst
flexibel
das stahlskelett ist elastisch gibt nach
und kann sich in relativ hohem maße
verbiegen ohne zusammenzufallen
ein erdbeben ist deshalb kein großes
problem für das empire state building
der wüstenstaat dubai wird zwar nicht
oft von erdbeben heimgesucht doch wenn
es geschieht sind die
grundvoraussetzungen nicht gerade
optimal der bauplatz des burj khalifa
liegt mitten in der wüste wie in ganz
dubai befindet sich unter dem sand
weißer kalkstein
der grund unter dem empire state
building aus festem granit besteht sind
dubais sand und kalkstein böden eine
denkbar schlechte grundlage für einen
erdbebensicheren wolkenkratzer dieser
größe
wie sorgt man unter solch ungünstigen
voraussetzungen für einen festen stand
auch hier setzen die bauherren vor allem
auf ein besonders stabiles fundament
es besteht aus über 800 betonpfählen die
bis zu 50 meter in die erde reichen
dreimal so tief wie beim empire state
building darauf kommt ein fast vier
meter dicker stahl betonsockel durch die
sogenannte pfahlgründung hält die
reibung des umgebenden sandes das
500.000 tonnen schwere gebäude selbst
bei erschütterungen stabil
zusätzlich ist wie beim empire state
building das stahlgerüst der ypsilon
konstruktion elastisch der innere stahl
beton kern sorgt für weitere stabilität
[Musik]
dadurch hält das höchste bauwerk der
erde sogar erdbeben bis stufe 6 auf der
richterskala stand
beeindruckend sowohl der burj khalifa
als auch das empire state building sind
dank ihrer flexiblen stahlkonstruktionen
und ihrer verstärkten fundamente gut
gegen erdbeben gewappnet
zeit für den letzten vergleich in sachen
stabilität denn es gibt noch eine
weitere gefahr die wolkenkratzern zum
verhängnis werden kann feuer
wie am 28 juli 1945 ein militärpilot
verirrt sich im nebel
und steuert seine maschine quer durch
manhattan
mit über 200 kilometern pro stunde
prallt der bomber gegen das 78 stockwerk
des empire state buildings
der einschlag riss ein etwa 33
quadratmeter großes loch ins gebäude
[Musik]
nach dem aufprall folgt eine explosion
rund 3000 liter flugzeugtreibstoff
ergossen sich in flur und fahrstuhl
vechte
mehrere stockwerke in brand
das empire state building steht in
flammen und zur damaligen zeit gibt es
noch keine automatischen
feuerlöschanlagen
dafür befinden sich über 400
wasserschlauch verbindungen im gebäude
gespeist über eine separate
wasserversorgung
[Musik]
glücklicherweise ist die
hauptwasserleitung noch intakt als die
feuerwehr beginnt den brand zu löschen
die büroangestellten versuchen über zwei
treppenhäuser den flammen zu entkommen
doch dort sammelt sich gefährliche rauch
bei einem hochhausbrand ist die
rauchentwicklung meist die größte gefahr
in den treppenhäusern staut sich die
luft damals kam es auch zu
rauchvergiftungen
14 menschen verlieren bei dem unglück
ihr leben
25 werden verletzt
doch durch seine robuste bauweise hält
das empire state building dem einschlag
stand und erleidet keine strukturellen
schäden
bereits zwei tage später öffnet der
wolkenkratzer wieder seine türen
und auch heute ist das brandschutzsystem
dank modernisierung auf dem neuesten
stand so dass die menschen im empire
state building auch in zukunft sicher
sind
wie gefährlich kann dem burj khalifa ein
feuer werden
die bauherren in dubai wollten nicht nur
das höchste bauwerk der welt erschaffen
sondern auch eines der sichersten der
kern des burj khalifa besteht aus beton
praktischer nebeneffekt das material
sorgt nicht nur für stabilität sondern
ist auch feuer resistent zudem verfügt
das gebäude über ein elektronisches
frühwarnsystem
sobald feuer einen rauchmelder einen
hitze sensor oder einen wasser sprinkler
auslöst springt ein ganzes netzwerk von
hochleistungs ventilatoren an
sie leiten saubere kühle luft nach innen
und verhindern so eine lebensbedrohliche
rauchentwicklung bei einer
kontrollierten evakuierung herrscht
meistens chaos damit die bewohner nicht
alle gleichzeitig evakuiert werden
müssen gibt es im burj khalifa spezielle
safe ruhms der burj khalifa verfügt über
neue schutzräume diese halten der hitze
eines feuers zwei stunden lang stand und
verfügen über eine eigene luftversorgung
etwa alle 25 stockwerke befindet sich
einer davon
sowohl in dubai als auch in new york
haben es die erbauer erfolgreich
geschafft ihre gebäude gegen feuer zu
schützen
fazit in der letzten kategorie
stabilität können sowohl das empire
state building als auch der burj khalifa
überzeugen fast 80 jahre liegen zwischen
dem bau des empire state buildings in
new york und dem des burj khalifa in
dubai
und ob in sachen architektur ausstattung
oder stabilität ob damals oder heute
beide gebäude setzen beeindruckende
maßstäbe
das empire state building bleibt die
mutter aller wolkenkratzer
und der burj khalifa setzt maßstäbe für
das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
[Musik]